un coup de main pour sauver une
entreprise en difficulté le département
des yvelines a décidé de soutenir la
firme dunlopillo ans permettant son
nouveau repreneur finadorm de ne pas
payer les murs de la structure dans un
premier temps au total ce sont près de 2
millions d'euros qui ont été avancées
par le 78 sur le site du groupe
implantée à limay ces demies en euros
que nous on n'a pas eu à investir
et et derrière forcément ces deux
millions d'euros qu'on va réinvestir
dans l'outil de production dans le
marketing le développement de nouvelles
gammes ce qui va créer du chiffre
d'affaires et du business évidemment
dans cette entreprise
oui c'est important une vraie bouffée
d'oxygène pour cette entreprise en
redressement judiciaire depuis décembre
2019 avec la reprise dalo pillot par
finadorm la moitié des 177 emplois en
cdi de l'industriel sera conservé soit
90 au total dans la clio s'est
extrêmement blé matic de ce que veut
faire le département des yvelines on
veut défendre l'emploi industriel
nous sommes le premier et bernie d'un
paradoxe département industriel d'île de
france
un des plus importants de france et nous
considérons que l'industrie est
constitutive de la richesse d'un pays
quand l'entreprise aura trouvé son
rythme de croisière à la rachètera les
murs au département des yvelines
finadorm espère redresser l'entreprise
d'ici cinq ans